bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du parlement hebdo compagnie de
mickaël zeze bonjour week-end dans
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
cette semaine la fin de la session
parlementaire dernière séance de
questions au gouvernement cette semaine
les députés qui rentrent dans leurs
circonscriptions vont se mobiliser pour
les présidentielles et surtout pour le
renouvellement de leur siège au mois de
juin
hommage appuyé de françois fillon aux
députés de sa majorité
l'exercice télévisuel pour nicolas
sarkozy cette semaine le président
candidat annoncé quelques réformes
multiplier les béats culpa sur le
fouquet's le yacht de bolloré ou encore
les propos d'anovo du salon de
l'agriculture et puis une nouvelle
confidence en fin de semaine s'il n'est
pas élu président il se retirera de la
vie politique
enfin la journée de la femme ce jeudi 10
mars les associations féministes ont
interpellé les candidats alors d'une
soirée à la cigale à paris selon à son
bal c'est françois hollande qui serait
perçu comme le meilleur candidat pour la
cause des femmes et il y à la dé façon
générale des progrès à faire
notre invité cette semaine avec nous
roselyne bachelot merci d'être avec nous
sur notre plateau ministre des
solidarités et bien sûr de la cohésion
sociale
alors j'ai fait un petit calcul rapide
cela fait maintenant dix ans que vous
êtes ministre de l'environnement à la
santé aux sports sous jacques chirac
puis nicolas sarkozy vous avez été
député député européenne mais vous avez
annoncé il ya peu de temps que vous ne
vous représenterez pas aux élections
législatives est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est la femme de votre vie politique
dont ce n'est pas la fin de ma vie
politique
mais je pense qu'il faut si la
respiration dans la vie politique je
suis rentrée au parlement en 1988
ça fait presque un quart de siècle j'y
ai vécu des moments formidables et cette
dernière séance de questions a été un
moment de nostalgie
parce que je crois que j'ai passé les
meilleurs moments de ma vie publique que
ce soit comme député comme ministre ici
au parlement est aussi bien à
l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat
mais là il faut respirer mais je vais
continuer à faire de la politique et
faire de la politique autrement allait
faire alors il ya plusieurs tâches
auxquelles je vais m'attacher d'abord
j'ai un certain nombre de livres qui
sont en préparation
certes un certain qu'ils vont paraître
certainement assez vite après la fin de
la campagne
non ma vie ne mérite pas une biographie
les dessous je voulais pas vous dire que
son voilà je n'en dirai pas plus
j'ai un livre qui est en préparation de
musique et puis un livre que je
consacrerai à la réforme de la politique
sociale dans notre pays c'est un très
gros sujets qui me demandera un peu plus
de temps je participerai bien entendu ou
débat public à travers mon parti
politique l'ump à travers vos
invitations
éventuellement je resterai une actrice
une actrice du débat public et je
souhaite travailler à la rénovation de
la vie publique
enfin quand même si et si nicolas
sarkozy est réélu et qu'il vous re
propose un poste de ministre vous vous
doutez bien sûr j'accepterai la belle
avec on ne retiendra asie remets
absolument pas je fais de la politique
autrement en étant mans ne représentant
pas à ce poste de député en en laissant
maintenant la responsabilité à mon
suppléant paul jeanneteau je l'avais
d'ailleurs je lui avais dit des
élections de 2007 en lui disant qu' il
serait le candidat en 2012 et que si je
quittais le gouvernement en cours de
mandature à la faveur d'un remaniement
jeunes
lui demanderai pas de me redonner ce
poste il le garderais jusqu'en 2012
alors on attendra évidemment vos livres
prochainement mais ce qu'il y à déjà à
présent vous pouvez nous révéler un
moment marquant dans votre vie politique
quelque chose qui vous a le plus marqué
sûrement qu'il fera l'objet d'un nouveau
ouvrage seulement il a déjà fait l'objet
d'un ouvrage de ma part c'est le pacs
c'est à l'évidence le discours que j'ai
prononcé à l'occasion du vote sur le
pacte civil de solidarité
je crois d'ailleurs que des députés
d'opposition de la majorité qui ont vécu
ce moment en ont reparlé de ce silence
inouï de ce moment d'émotion absolument
incroyable qui saisit c'est le président
d'alors c'était raymond forni le
socialiste les députés qui étaient là
les personnes qui assistaient dans la
dans les tribunes du public et j'ai eu
un moment d'émotion que je pense
personne n'a eu dans sa vie politique ou
très rarement un jour je sortais de du
métro à la station à la station
invalides et un passager s'est mis
devant moi sur le quai du métro est il à
réciter par coeur il m'a réciter par
coeur le discours que j'avais prononcé
et on était tous les deux
tous les deux en larmes je pense que
c'est quelque chose d'unique
notre grande fierté on va dérouler
ensemble si vous le voulez bien
l'actualité de la semaine c'est le
principe de l'émission va commencer avec
le lundi bien sûr françois hollande
sera-t-il victime d'un complot des
consommateurs européens
ce sont les journalistes allemands du
chp eagle qui l'affirment des dirigeants
européens se seraient concertés aurait
décidé de ne pas recevoir le candidat
françois hollande
une fronde conservatrice catégoriquement
démenties par les intéressés et when he
là il y a quelques semaines elle s'était
rendu en personne à l'elysée pour
afficher sa préférence
angela merkel soutient inconditionnel de
nicolas sarkozy serait peut-être aller
plus loin
depuis ce week end une révélation du
très sérieux hebdomadaire allemand der
spiegel met en cause l'attitude de la
chancelière qui aurait convaincu ses
homologues italien anglais espagnol de
ne pas recevoir le candidat socialiste
une alliance anti hollande évoqué avec
prudence par le principal intéressé
ce que je veux dire à ses dirigeants
c'est que c'est le peuple français qui
va décider de son avenir
ce ne sont pas des dirigeants européens
que je respecte par ailleurs qu'ils
doivent peser sur la décision du peuple
français informations embarrassantes
aussitôt démentie par berlin madrid et
londres pour la plupart les chefs d'état
visés par l'article ont pourtant un
point commun conservateurs ils sont
aussi à l'origine d'un nouveau traité
européen de discipline budgétaire que
françois hollande souhaite renégocier
pour comprendre que le droit de
européenne s'émeuvent de la position de
françois hollande mais françois hollande
demain s'il est élu président de la
république ne veut pas être l'otage des
politiques d'austérité d'un traité qui
institutionnalise l'austérité alors
faut-il voir derrière ce présumé boycott
un signe de ralliement à nicolas sarkozy
ou même une demande du président
candidat pour jeter le discrédit sur la
stature internationale de son concurrent
beaucoup d'accusations démenti ce matin
par le premier ministre françois
hollande se se fait plus gros qui n'est
je dire l'idée même que tous ces chefs
de gouvernement ce téléphone pour parler
de lui est une idée auquel personne dans
en tout cas qui connaît le
fonctionnement des états ne peut croire
un seul instant après ses homologues
européens nicolas sarkozy a à son tour
récusé tout boycott organisé pour lui
c'est une rumeur absurde d'ailleurs un
petit peu
un petit peu amusant alors il ya un vrai
problème c'est que effectivement pour
sortir de la crise il ne peut y avoir
qu'une démarche européenne concertée
fait évidemment en harmonie avec nos
autres partenaires nous sommes arrivés à
un accord difficilement chacun ya mis du
sien et la parole de la france est
évidemment engagés dans cette affaire et
que françois hollande pour des motifs
électoralistes 1002 évidemment de mettre
mettre le trouble là dedans et
extrêmement est extrêmement inquiétant
maintenant effectivement ce sont des
amis qui sont là monsieur cameron madame
merkel ils n'ont pas très envie
peut-être de recevoir quelqu'un qui
vient soutenir leurs adversaires
politiques on peut peut-être mais
comprend outre la part de vérité ou de
positionnement politique
c'est un problème d'abord de
positionnement politique bien sûr
françois au louvre pour ckoi de sa
campagne annuelle et vous surprend non
il me surprend pas je connais françois
hollande depuis longtemps gelé vue je l'
ai vu en tant que député j'ai été sa
collègue à l'assemblée nationale bien
entendu je le connais bien
sa compagne est en jeu vivent donc je
les connais bien c'est un homme
politique c'est un homme politique de
qualité évidemment je pense que le parti
socialiste n'a pas choisi de le pire de
ces candidats putatifs pour aller
peut-être le jour à savoir la campagne
le plus dangereux pour nicolas sarkozy
c'est difficile c'est difficile à dire
là vous me posez une question à laquelle
je ne peux pas répondre mais c'est un
adversaire qui a évidemment à ses côtés
l'ensemble du parti socialiste même si
derrière on voit bien que les certains
poignard sont cachés derrière les
rideaux et que c'est dans tous les sens
doute dans tous les partis mais enfin il
a plu toute la sarkozie qu'au tour de
france je le connaissais bien ce coup
quand même vous êtes étonné par sa
pugnacité parce que c'est quelqu'un
avant le bourget notamment qu'on avait
voilà qualifié de gauche molle y compris
dans ses rangs
boury qu'il l'avait qui l'avait traité
de nous enfin bon alors sur moi c'est
des histoires du parti socialiste je ne
doute pas qu'un candidat à la
présidentielle soit combatif est
soi-même boostait par ce choix de son
propre camp ça donne une énergie
cela donne une énergie farouche que
d'être porté par ses troupes
donc même si il n'a pas brillé comme
leader du parti socialiste et moi qu'on
en puisse dire et je dois dire que ses
amis politiques qui en parle le mieux et
qu'ils ont fait sur lui les critiques
les plus les plus ardentes et les plus
méchantes ma foi je suis pas militante
du parti socialiste je m'en référer à ce
qu'en ont dit ses amis dans une bâche
lova présent parler d'un rapport que
vous avez commandé à chantal jouanno une
sénatrice
un phénomène encore un peu marginale en
france mais qui arrive à crier vitesse
grand v on les appelle les lolitas c'est
l'hyper sexualisation des jeunes filles
ou comment la pub et la société
transforme nos enfants le détail de ce
rapport avec flora sauvage des fillettes
qui pose dans des tenues sexy sous
l'oeil des caméras
les concours de mini miss se développe
en france chantal jouanno préconise
d'interdire ces concours de beauté pour
fillettes dans son rapport sur l'hyper
sexualisation des enfants revit ce matin
à la ministre roselyne bachelot la
sénatrice de paris présente ses douze
propositions pour lutter contre le
phénomène avec des très fortes
elle commence dès le plus jeune âge on
l'a vu avec la réapparition de jouets de
tenues qui sont quand même très
sexualisée
ray clivante entre garçons et filles et
puis surtout à partir de l'adolescence
et ce concept de préadolescents on
essaye de créer un nouveau marché pour
accentuer ce phénomène si l'hyper
sexualisation est encore un phénomène
marginal en france chantal jouanno
propose de créer une charte de l'enfant
elle préconise aussi l'éducation au
respect et à l'égalité entre les sexes
dès le primaire
enfin chantal jouanno propose de créer
un forum sur internet qui permettrait
aux citoyens et aux parents de dénoncer
des entreprises ou des médias qui ne
respecteraient pas l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant à charge pour les
entreprises de répondre ou de voir leur
nom cité publiquement comme ne
respectant pas l'intérêt de l'enfant
alors roselyne bachelot sur ce phénomène
des rapports des missions
mais que peuvent faire le gouvernement
légiférer d'abord je veux rendre hommage
au travail remarquable de chantal
jouanno qui a vraiment bien poser le
problème la définit à proposer des axes
d'action nous ne sommes pas dans notre
pays et c'est fort heureux sur un
phénomène d'hypersexualisation massive
comme cela peut exister dans certains
pays
dans certains pays anglo saxons il ya
une sorte de consensus social bien
marqué par chantal jouanno pour refuser
cette démarche mais nous voyons comme
des signes avant coureurs qui montre
qu'il faut être vigilant et qu'on est
beaucoup plus actif si on est dans la
prévention du phénomène sur
l'information des familles alors d'abord
il y a des choses que sur lequel on peut
interdire pense au concours de mini-miss
par exemple qui sont pas utiles nos
enfants n'ont pas à défiler sur des
podiums je divise en jeu premier élément
des mesures des mesures d'interdiction
voilà celle là sans études ont participé
à des par exemple qu'une petite fille
soit l'égérie d'une marque
il faut aussi beaucoup d'information
vis-à-vis des parents en leur indiquant
que cette démarche n'est pas innocente
mais les mamans qui font ça n'ont pas
l'intention d'y père sexualisé les leur
petite fille je les condamne pages les
jeux les stigmatise pas je dis
simplement qu'elle les mette dans une
démarche de pure séduction et nous nous
sommes en train de lutter pour que nos
filles deviennent des mathématicienne
des chercheurs
des chefs d'entreprise des médecins et
on leur ont finalement on leur dit façon
subliminale la chose qui compte c'est
que vous soyez un objet de consommation
et de séduction de la société de la
publicité alors donc il faut il faut
évidemment former informer les parents
les médias aussi moi ce que je remarque
c'est que quand je décroche mon
téléphone et je les fais à de nombreuses
reprises
quand je vois quelque chose qui cloche
comme je les ai vus dans une revue très
glamour qui avait pris des photos de
petites filles dans des positions
lascives
mais les rédacteurs en chef sont les
premiers à dire oui vous avez raison on
n'a pas été assez vigilant et les
démarches sur le type de charles
démarche volontariste sont très bien
accepté par les médias sont très bien
acceptée aussi par les fabricants de
cosmétiques ou de vêtements est ce que
le danger le plus grand parce que
vraiment incontrôlable celui là ce n'est
pas les réseaux sociaux vous voir les
les petites filles qui se font des
profils sur certains réseaux et ça
finalement
l'état ne peut rien ça peut être
éventuellement les parents mais mais
guère plus vous avez raison de dire que
les codes de la pornographie ont envahi
l'espace public et que bien entendu dans
les esprits dans l'espace public régi
par les médias classiques ya toutes
sortes de sauvegarde mais que dans
l'espace delà des nouveaux réseaux dans
l'espace d'internet les mêmes mécanismes
de sauvegarde ne sont pas là ont bien
sûr il ya un contrôle parental et on
peut le mettre
évidemment il faut le mettre en oeuvre
mais par exemple pour les films
pornographiques
le contrôle parental ne se déclenche
qu'après qu'on ait vu en quelque sorte
le teasing de ses films pornographiques
donc on a accès à la pornographie de
façon illimitée nos enfants ont accès à
la pornographie
donc là il faut aller plus loin dans le
contrôle parental et que le contrôle
parental puisse se déclencher
automatiquement une belge devra passer
au mardi c'est la fin de session pour
les parlementaires
pour cause d'élections présidentielle et
législatives la session parlementaire
s'achève dernière séance de questions au
gouvernement en ce mardi l'hémicycle
connaît la fréquentation des grands
jours on sort les téléphones portables
pour les photos souvenirs faut dire que
certains députés volontairement ou non
ne retrouveront pas à leur siège en juin
prochain
après cinq ans passés sur ces bancs
l'heure est à la congratuler à sion en
tout cas du côté de la majorité on
écoute les idées notre assemblée au
cours de cette 13e législature a été un
grand honneur
nos échanges ont été parfois vives
toujours nourri mais le plus souvent
fructueux on peut être pour ou contre
les réformes que nous avons accompli on
peut les juger trop ambitieuse où on
peut au contraire les jugés trop
modestes mais personne ne peut dire que
nous n'avons pas agi avec sincérité et
avec la volonté de répondre à l'intérêt
national
roselyne bachelot vous disiez tout à
l'heure que c'est avec une certaine
émotion vous avez vécu cette dalle un
sens vous avez sorti l'appareil photo
mais aussi mais j'ai eu la chance j'ai
eu l'opportunité d'avoir à répondre à
trois questions oui sans les femmes ur
de ses vertus de cette dernière
cette dernière séance et j'ai été très
heureuse que les trois questions de de
la majorité de l'opposition et une de la
majorité de marie jo zimmermann soit
l'occasion de faire le bilan nicolas
sarkozy en matière d'égalité d'égalité
homme-femme à la veille de cette journée
du 8 mars
on a vu quand même une session en fin de
cette législature parfois un peu agité
les socialistes ont quitté l'hémicycle
gouvernement récemment aussi a quitté
l'hémicycle
vous l'avez trouvé plus agités cette
session que la précédente
finalement non c'est toujours le jeu le
jeu parlementaire on le connais bien je
suis vieille
par le j'ai vu un certain nombre de
clash
j'ai même vu quelques fois c'était
pierre mazeaud qui présidait le une
séance au moment du débat sur la les 35
heures avec martine aubry quitté l'ue le
président a quitté les sa tribune est
véritablement mettre en émoi l'ensemble
de ce qu'on appelle le plateau attire
les fonctionnaires qui sont là qu'il est
avait maintenant à notre président un
autre vice président pour présider la
séance
on voit ça avec le risque certain flair
tout et n'importe quand on écoute et
françois fillon je vouvoyais regardez et
écoutez évidemment cette déclaration
vous vous devez beaucoup finalement à
françois fillon au cours de ce
quinquennat
ah oui françois fillon est un ami
extrêmement fidèle il peut compter sur
ma loyauté sur ma fidélité les ténors et
dans une certaine polémique quand vous
étiez ministre de la santé oms rappelle
des problèmes dus à la grippe h5n1 et
h1n1 pardon il y avait une certaine
polémique qui avait enflammé la presse
françois fillon vous avez beaucoup aidé
à l'ewi il n'a d'autant plus céder que
les décisions ont été prises sous son
égide est qu'aucune des décisions que
j'ai prises n'avaient évidemment toutes
les décisions que j'ai prises avait
recueilli l'aval et l'accord de françois
fillon et du président de la république
on ne prend pas ses décisions seul sait
pas toujours pour ça qu'on est soutenue
derrière c'est vrai je le reconnais je
suis loyal vis-à-vis de françois et
françois et loyal vis-à-vis de moi il
est en responsabilité
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je laime et
le soutien fin de session d'en parler
l'occasion pour nous justement de faire
le bilan en cinq ans plus de 250 lois
ont été votées malgré cela le nombre de
réformes emblématiques sont restées en
suspens le détail avec thomas raguet on
en avait tellement entendu parler qu'on
les croyait déjà en vigueur pourtant de
nombreuses lois annoncées n'ont pas vu
le jour
réforme de la dépendance règle d'or ou
encore référendum d'initiative citoyenne
et parlementaires certes il ya des lois
qui ont été engagés et donc on n'a pas
pu achever la de la discussion mais
toutes celles que le gouvernement le
président d'art public voulait voir
voter l'ont été et saas est à l'honneur
du gouvernement
pourtant certaines ont été souhaités par
nicolas sarkozy comme la réforme du
statut pénal du chef de l'état
on sait très bien qu'il faut revoir le
statut pénal du chef de l'état les
rapports entre le chef de l'état est la
justice monsieur sarkozy le sait très
bien puisque c'est dans les
modifications de la constitution qu'il a
introduites mais toujours est il qu'il
se sera débrouillée pour que depuis le
début jusqu'à la fin de son quinquennat
jamais une loi ne soit votée à ce sujet
or c'est nécessaire et bien entendu nous
le ferons
ça fait partie des engagements forts de
françois hollande loi sur les conflits
d'intérêts texte sur la protection des
consommateurs responsabilité des
ministres en tant que comptable public
les textes en déshérence sont nombreux
si le passage à gauche du sénat explique
le blocage de certaines réformes comme
celle de la règle d'or budgétaire ce
sont surtout des choix politiques qui en
sont la cause parce qu'il ya eu d'autres
priorités parce qu'on a passé des
semaines et c'est normal sur la réforme
des retraites hausse urnes et des sujets
sur un des sujets majeurs
d'autres sont apparus moins important
264 lois ont été votées au cours de la
législature
ces 27 de plus que pour la précédente
déjà très chargé 264 lois votées au
cours du quinquennat roselyne bachelot
mais une loi importante qui devait être
la loi majeures du quinquennat celle sur
l'indépendance que vous devez porter a
été faite finalement presque à minima
c'est à regret d'abord je veux dire que
j'ai été porteuse intec extrêmement
important d'une réforme majeure du
quinquennat c'est la réforme du système
de santé tout noir très importante qui a
donné lieu à des débats nourris
l'installation des agences régionales de
santé pour territorialisée les
politiques de santé décloisonner c'est
très important pour la réforme de la
dépendance et je vais y revenir le
sanitaire et le médico social avec des
dispositions de santé publique
importante la rénovation de l'hôpital et
de la gouvernance de l'hôpital et un
certain nombre de me
ils commencent à porter leurs fruits
pour la démographie médicale
alors nous n'avons pas pu à cause des
difficultés financières de notre pays
prendre en ce qui concerne la réforme de
la dépendance les mesures financières
les plus lourdes mais bien entendu nous
avons commencé la réforme de la
dépendance et je vous rend attentifs au
fait que les crédits pour les personnes
âgées ont augmenté de 75 pour cent
pendant le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy et etc alors que nous étions en
pleine crise
nous avons lors du vote des dernières
lois de financement montaient les
crédits 6% et posées dans la loi
à certain nombre de réformes extrêmement
un fait dedans est allé plus loin c'est
dû à la crise voilà exactement c'est
pour cela que pendant les vacances c'est
pour ça qu'au moment jusqu'au mois
d'août nous avons pensé que
financièrement
nous pourrions prendre les mesures
financières les plus coûteuses et puis
la situation financière européenne la
situation de l'économie européenne nous
a amenés à retarder ces dispositions
bien entendu le travail qui a été fait
et continuera à être un réservoir pour
les dispositions à prendre
mais d'ores et déjà par exemple des
mesures très fortes comme les
indicateurs de qualité dans les
établissements la meilleure information
des dp des familles tout cela a été
commencé allez on revient maintenant sur
la polémique qui a beaucoup que peut
occuper les débats
la consommation de viande halal en ce
mardi c'est une phrase de françois
fillon qui rallume l' incendie
il suggère aux religions de revenir sur
cette tradition ancestrale et cela
déplaît jusque dans la majorité thomas
souligner c'est la petite phrase qui a
mis le feu aux poudres hier matin
françois fillon s'en est pris aux rites
musulmans et juifs halal casher des
traditions d'un autre temps selon le
premier ministre
l'honneur il ya des traditions qui sont
des traditions ancestrales qui
correspondent plus à grand chose alors
qu'elle correspondait dans le passé à
des problèmes d'hygiène
on pourrait y réfléchir nicolas sarkozy
s'est déclaré en faveur de l'étiquetage
de la viande en fonction de la méthode
d'abattage
mais voilà en 18 mois deux propositions
de loi ont été déposées sur le sujet
mais rejetée par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui l'idée est largement
condamné par les organisations juives
si l'étiquetage il y a il y as
stigmatisation les problèmes de la
france ont tellement important nous
sommes en période de crise
en quoi le problème de la viande casher
est un problème majeur
mais là je parle pour le juif que je
suis et je ne réponds pas à la place des
musulmans en quoi et qui n'apprenait
majeur pour la france une polémique qui
embarrasse au sein même de la majorité
à moins de 50 jours de l'élection
présidentielle
je crois que c'est une erreur c'est une
faute une chose parce qu'on doit
respecter les religions toutes les
religions on doit les respecter on n'est
pas ici au dessus des religions pour
leur dire ce qu'il faut qu'elle fasse je
pense qu'il ya d'autres sujets de
préoccupation des français même si celui
là en est un mais vous savez entre les
difficultés d'un jeune pour trouver son
premier emploi des gens qui sont en
chômage de longue durée
redonner des points de compétitivité à
nos entreprises y aussi d'autres sujets
de mobilisation finie la controverse
l'ump veut désormais tourner la page en
guise d'apaisement
françois fillon recevra jeudi les
représentants du culte musulman
roselyne bachelot vous qui connaissait
bien françois fillon homme réputé modéré
pourquoi est il allé s'empêtrer dans
cette polémique
d'abord je veux dire deux choses très
simples je ne vois pas pourquoi ils sont
pas normales qui a un étiquetage c'est
un sujet très important qui est un
étiquetage vois pas où est la la
stigmatisation les consommateurs ont le
droit d'être informés premier point
deuxième point je remarque finalement le
recteur de la mosquée grande mosquée de
paris dalil boubakeur pour lequel
d'ailleurs j'ai le plus profond respect
a lui même indiqué qu'il convenait que
sur ces techniques d'abattage rituel on
avance et il a souhaité lui même qu' il
y ait des évolutions dans ces techniques
d'abattage rituel état de 200
c'est un débat républicain et beaucoup
de personnes qui défendent par exemple
les animaux ont été ou étaient choqués
par les techniques d'abattage rituel
donc le recteur de la mosquée de paris a
indiqué que dans le cadre du nain
d'évitement de la cruauté envers les
animaux il convenait d'avancé sur ces
techniques dont acte tout cela tout d'un
coup prend un aspect exacerbé ce tableau
sans ça il n'a pas été laissée par nous
il a été relayé quand même par le
gouvernement lui-même la parole à claude
vézina pas être il n'a pas été lancée
par nous et ma foi puisque le sujet sur
mario blais pas qu'il semble intéresser
les français qu'il semble intéresser les
français
le gouvernement est dans son rôle d'y
répondre mais là pourquoi françois
fillon est intervenu sur ce sujet qu'il
sait peut-être un petit parce qu'ils y
sont parce qu'il a été interrogé et il a
répondu c'est tout à fait normal il se
doit de répond ou polémique qui a servi
à rien finalement
comme l'a dit nicolas sarkozy lui-même
après en avoir parlé quand il son
déplacement à rungis il est tout à fait
évident que de la part de madame le pen
de lancer ce sujet est un signe de
faiblesse politique elle s'est empêtrée
dans un discours économique qui a été
mal ficelée et qui a révélé ses
incompétences en ce domaine
elle s'est rendue compte qu'elle avait
joué les précieuses ridicules dans ce
domaine et elle s'est recentré sur des
sujets qui font qu'ils font florès au
front national
je le mets ces sujets c'est super mais
ces sujets sont passionnés ces sujets
sont dans l'espace public on y répond
parce qu'ils intéressent aussi certains
français c'est normal on est interpellé
vous interpeller vous a interpellé
pendant plusieurs minutes sur ce sujet
j'y réponds le parti qui fut la clé
oui ça fait l'actualité que voulez vous
je préfèrerais que m'interroger sur
autre chose
mardi ce sont nicolas sarkozy peut-être
le défi était de taille pour le
président relancer sa campagne au moment
crucial où l'opinion se cristallisent il
était l'invité de l'émission de france 2
des paroles et des actes le président
candidat a le nouveau détailler ses
idées tout en se dévoilant il est revenu
une nouvelle fois sur cette soirée au
fouquet's
écoutez il y en a sans doute beaucoup
qui ont vécu ce que j'ai vécu
la page est tournée mais je leur demande
à eux de comprendre une chose quand on a
vécu ça est ce qu'on a envie d'y revenir
de quoi parlez vous c'est à dire le
mélange entre eu l'immense honneur comme
faisait les français ce jour-là d'être
élu et ma famille qui explosait que ce
qui aurait dû être le couronnement de ma
vie professionnelle en tout cas je dois
dire qu'une partie de ma tête était
consacrée à d'autres problèmes
roselyne bachelot je vous demanderai pas
si vous avez été convaincu par nicolas
sarkozy je pense que je connais la
réponse par contre cet acte de mea culpa
est-ce qu'il était nécessaire et ce
qu'ils arrivent trop tard
il est d'autant plus nécessaire que on
n'entend parler que de ça et qu'on
résume le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
parfois à trois quarts d'heures passées
dans un restaurant parisien sans
s'immiscer vraiment c'est vraiment
tellement vrai tellement réducteur et
d'ailleurs je constate qu'une grande
partie des mis entre 20 minutes et une
demi-heure 3 que trois quarts d'heure a
été consacrée à ça il y en a ras-le-bol
pardon il y en a six mois ces voix là
mais ça sent du coeur ça sort du coeur
quand on voit le bilan de nicolas
sarkozy président de la république le
travail de modernisation qu'il a fait de
notre pays
on a parlé de la réforme des retraites
de la réforme du système de santé de la
réforme des universités
nous sommes ici au parlement de l'aider
extraordinaire avancée démocratique qui
ont été menées durant ce durant ce
quinquennat sous contrôle de l'elysée
pour la première fois des déluges est de
l'elysée alors vraiment parlons de ça
parce que ça c'est important mais deux
mots comme un mot pour finir sur cette
question il avait besoin d'extérioriser
tout cela il a besoin d'en parler pour
essayer avec oui je crois qu'il avait
besoin de ça c'est exaspérant
d'abord c'est exaspérant il avait envie
d'y répondre
et c'était son rôle de président de la
république dans son bien gouda c'était
son rôle de président de la république
d'y répondre et d'expliquer devant les
français ce qui s'est passé
le dire avec beaucoup d'humanité
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de sincérité
il a dit finalement ce que tout le monde
savait qu'ils traversent un très bon
très mauvais moment dans sa vie
personnelle je me savais j'en ai jamais
parlé mais comme j'étais proche de nuit
j'ai vu j'ai vu de loin avec discrétion
ses difficultés à quel point ils avaient
de la peine
voilà c'est tout il l'a dit il l'a dit
très simplement français vous vous
n'êtes pas dans l'équipe de campagne de
quelle façon je suis dans l'équipe de
campagne mais pas dans dans le petit
local de campagne quelle façon les
ministres au gouvernement participe-t-il
aujourd'hui à la campagne du président
candidat est bien de façon dont nous l'a
indiqué nicolas sarkozy nous a dit vous
êtes des professionnels de la politique
vous n'avez pas besoin que je vous donne
des consignes vous vous faites votre
campagne et c'est ce que je fais j'ai
déjà tenu des dizaines de réunions et
déploie tous les jours a à faire
pratiquement une réunion une réunion par
jour pour défendre le bilan de nicolas
sarkozy pour présenter ses propositions
je suis totalement mobilisé sur l'accord
est organiste tous les ministres ne sont
pas comme vous ils auraient aimé
peut-être avoir un petit sous moi je
vais la part de nicolas jault cours dans
mon couloir je sais exactement ce que je
dois faire pour le président de la
république
vous savez je tient des réunions
pratiquement sur un seul thème le bilan
social de nicolas sarkozy
car rarement autant n'a été fait en
matière de politique sociale politique
ans pour les personnes en situation de
handicap pour les familles pour les
familles fragiles pour les personnes
âgées et j'ai eu la surprise de voir
d'ailleurs dans ces réunions des
militants ou des sympathisants sortir un
papier un crayon et noter les chiffres
que je leur donne et me dire après les
réunions mais il faut nous parler de ça
il faut nous parler du bilan social de
nicolas sarkozy une réunion par jour ça
vous laisse le temps de vous occuper des
ennuis vous savez mes journées non pas
huit heures à mes journées pour plutôt
vers 15 16 heures donc quand je fais une
réunion à café politique par exemple
xiiie arrondissement pour soutenir
anne-sophie souhaité je mens une heure
j'ai 14 heures pour travailler sur les
sujets alors le président candidat est
décidément dans sa semaine de
confidences il a dit cette fois face à
une caméra qu'en cas d'échec il se
retirait de la vie politique jusque là
il le disait en off on écoute si vous
perdez le 6 mai le 7 mai vous abandonner
la politique vous pouvez me poser la
question une troisième non mais je vous
le dis oui oui je ferai autre chose
jolie ville quoi je ne sais pas bon on
fait beaucoup de bruit mais ce n'est pas
vraiment un scoop on se doute bien qu'il
n'y a guère de vie politique après une
présidence mais est ce que c'est un bon
calcul de dire cela est ce que les
troupes ne se sentent pas lâcher je veux
dire des choses très simples et enfonce
des portes ouvertes vous ne voudrez pas
d'abord quand on se présente à une
élection à moins de se présenter en
corée du nord est d'être le fils du
guide suprême la défaite c'est toujours
quelque chose qu'on envisage et qu'on se
doit d'envisager non pas que la deuxième
est le deuxième élément c'est que moi je
suis gaulliste et que la position de
sarkozy nicolas sarkozy pardon du
président de la république est une
position éminemment gaullienne vous
imaginez après avoir quitté la
présidence de la république le président
de gaulle charles de gaulle de venir
chez pas moi président du conseil
général de l'aube
non je ne crois pas j'ai le plus grand
respect pour le président du conseil
général de l'ont bien entendu mais voilà
quand on a été président de la
république
si le sort des urnes ne vous est pas
favorable eh bien ma foi vous en tirez
vous en tirer les conséquences
est-ce que ça a un effet démobilisateur
je crois qu'on ait fait ça peut avoir au
contraire
en effet au contraire ça peut avoir un
effet mobilisateur avoir d'aidé des
militants des sympathisants qui se
disent bon ben voilà faut sortir vous
faut sous faut sortir du bois il faut se
mobiliser
le bilan de nicolas sarkozy est très bon
laisse les solutions qui nous propose
sont les solutions qui sont adaptées à
la crise à la crise actuelle et et voilà
ben allez on fonce donc évoqué sa
défaite ça n'est pas anticipé il ya pas
de prophétie auto-réalisatrice ans
devait aller va passer aux mercredis du
renfort pour françois bayrou
voilà une réponse à ceux qui se disent
que c'est un homme seul françois bayrou
enregistre ce mercredi un soutien de 18
sénateurs à cette occasion il a rappelé
sa ligne politique il reste insensible
aux clins d'oeil pourtant appuyé la
veille de nicolas sarkozy et le rejette
les appels du pied de la gauche bref
françois bayrou poursuit sa route
farouche qui n'est plus une photo de
famille un soulagement pour françois
bayrou le ralliement de ses sénateurs
centristes de diverses tendances met fin
à son image de candidat isolé
c'est un événement très important bien
entendu parce qu'ils répondent à la
question perpétuelle qu'on entend poser
qu'est la question de la solitude
l'un des grands artisans de ce
rassemblement derrière françois bayrou
c'est jean arthuis et pour lui ce ne
serait qu'une première étape
attendons les jours et les semaines qui
viennent
constater sans doute de nouveaux
rapprochements et
franchement semblement centrale en
attendant ce matin ils étaient seize
sénateurs centristes et deux non
inscrits à se présenter au siège du
modem 16 sur un groupe de 31 au sénat un
ralliement attendu pour valider la
stratégie de françois bayrou sur tout ce
qui est important c'est ce que propose
françois bayrou c'est à dire dans une
crise comme celle là d'être avec une
équipe d'union nationale prendre les
meilleurs de gauche les meilleurs de
droite pour les meilleurs de droite
il faudra encore attendre et ce matin
françois bayrou a multiplié les appels
du pied aux déçus de la campagne de
nicolas sarkozy
je suis sûr de leur malaise
en face de ces orientations et moi en
tout cas j'ai l'intention de ne pas
tomber dans ce genre de piège et de
récuser ce genre de débats qui sont pas
autre chose que des diversions et des
divisions
le candidat centriste veut croire que
l'image de cette famille recomposée se
prolonge après la présidentielle et que
le modem pèse aux législatives
mais ce noyau familial semblait encore
bien fragile ce matin roselyne bachelot
est ce que vous considérez françois
bayrou est un homme seul
on est toujours seul quand on est dans
une campagne présidentielle c'est vrai
qu'il a pas beaucoup trop autour de lui
et les images qu'on vient de voir était
un peu un peu pathétique mais moi ce que
je note surtout c'est que je comprends
qu'ils ne
disent pas qui veut se rallier au
deuxième tour il sera pas il sera pas a
priori au deuxième tour en tout cas mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que je connais
bien l'électorat de françois bayrou
puisque je suis d'un département où
françois bayroux chaque fois qu'il s'est
présenté à faire très supérieur à la
moyenne de la tradition centriste
démocrate chrétienne est très forte dans
mon département du maine-et-loire et que
les électeurs et les élus de françois
bayrou je les connais bien je travaille
avec eux ce sont les électeurs de la
droite et du centre
ce sont des gens avec lesquels nous
avons géré les collectivités locales
avec lesquelles m'avoue nous retrouvons
lors des élections législatives au
minimum au deuxième tour ce sont des
électeurs qui ont toujours voté pour moi
dans les cinq élections législatives
auxquelles je veux présenter puisque et
rejoindre nicolas sarkozy
de toute façon peu importe les consignes
qui seront passées ce sont des électeurs
qui se retrouvent profondément dans les
valeurs de la droite et du centre
et donc dans les valeurs qui sont
portées par nicolas sarkozy oui peu
importe les consignes c'est à dire même
s'il donne pas de consignes dans
maintenant les consignes des uns et des
autres quel qu'il soit ne compte pour
rien c'est la date d'un siècle révolu où
on venait demander pour qui il faut
voter non les électeurs ils se font
leurs idées donc les 12 13 % que vaud le
valais aujourd'hui mais jamais sur
bayrou on n'est jamais propriétaire de
ses doigts il y aura pas un appel de la
droite pour essayer de récupérer les
voix centristes
il n'y a pas besoin d'un appel de l'ump
les électeurs sont adultes ils se
retrouveront dans les valeurs et les
propositions que nous faisons
je prends un exemple françois bayroux
dit et répète qu'il a été le seul en
2007 a attiré l'attention sur l'état
calamiteux des finances publiques dont
acte écoutez sur ce simple diagnostic
il doit se retrouver dans les
propositions de nicolas sarkozy et non
pas dans les propositions dépensière de
françois hollande
roselyne bachelot on va passer à une
journée qui vous tient à coeur c'est
jeudi et c'est la journée de la femme
vivement
journée de la femme avec une résonance
particulière cette année puisque les
associations féministes interpelle les
candidats sur le thème c'est ce qu'elles
ont fait la veille au soir à la cigale
il y avait sur place pierre lascars et
clémentine malgré les organisatrices
avaient invité à la soirée tous les
candidats et candidates à la
présidentielle au final aucun candidat
de droite n'a répondu présent une
absence qui n'est pas passée inaperçue
nous avons sollicité le candidat nicolas
sarkozy qui n'a pas répondu à notre
demande et monsieur françois bayrou a
décliné notre invitation ne pouvait pas
venir non plus mais nous regrettons
qu'il n'y ait pas de candidat de droite
qui soit là aujourd'hui
à gauche les prétendants à l'elysée ont
défilé à la tribune objectif tenter de
séduire un électorat féminin mais
surtout féministe chacun essaie alors de
se démarquer de ses concurrents moi on
me l'a jouera pas sur
je suis l'ami des femmes parce que j'en
parle et que j'ai créé un ministère qui
ont créé un ministère c'est pour faire
quelque chose et un ministère du droit
des femmes qu'est ce qui doit faire du
social donc moi je porte l'idée d'une
action beaucoup plus volontariste rendre
obligatoire la réponse de la parité dans
les conseils d'administration sous peine
de dissolution du côté de françois
hollande on préfère rester prudent et
éviter les promesses kun pourrait tenir
je n'ai pas fixé d'objectifs chiffrés
pour les places en crèche telles que
vous les avez rappelé je préfère le dire
parce que je ne peux pas aujourd'hui
m'engageais financièrement sur un tel
objectif mais
mais je recueille les sifflets comme il
les kabyles sont mérités mais qu'est ce
que ce serait si je voulais vous dire
vous aurez si je suis élu président à
blick 500000 base est capable 500 mille
places si la question des droits des
femmes restent encore au second plan de
la campagne présidentielle
les féministes ont d'ores et déjà
prévenu elle compte bien rappeler aux
candidats leurs promesses en temps et en
heure alors vous ne l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous allez est interpellé trois
fois encore un questions au gouvernement
à la dernière session dit loi à peu près
sur les conditions des femmes est
toujours un écart salarial un écart dans
les carrières
c'est un des sujets les plus difficiles
à traiter
on voit bien que l'arsenal législatif
nous l'avons la loi sur l'égalité
salariale l'obligation de l'égalité
salariale elle date de 1972 et que nous
avons perfectionné le dispositif la loi
sur les violences en juillet en juillet
2010 la loi sur la réforme des retraites
qui a imposé les sanctions financières
aux entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
qui n'ont pas des objectifs et des
indicateurs en matière d'égalité
madame eva joly découvre lui demande de
mettre ces fiches à jour l'obligation de
la parité dans les conseils
d'administration c'est fait voilà je
l'informent il est temps à ce moment de
la campagne de la campagne électorale et
puis ça que fait françois sauvadet qui
vient d'être votée d'ailleurs sur au
moins 40 % de femmes dans les postes au
de hautes responsabilités dans la
fonction publique une armée mais ce que
je fais par exemple dans la lutte contre
les stéréotypes de genre à travers
l'hypersexualisation la lutte contre
l'hypersexualisation des petites filles
c'est de dire aussi aux petites filles
vous pouvez pas vous cantonnez d'être
seulement dans 10% des filières et il
faut absolument que l'ensemble des
éducateurs des parents se disent oui il
faut que les filles soient dans les
filières scientifiques là où il ya les
meilleures rémunérations les meilleures
perspectives de carrière
on a beau faire une loi sur l'égalité
professionnelle si dans l'entreprise le
garçon est un génie
heures et la fille secrétaire il y aura
toujours des inégalités de salaires
bachelot qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la proposition de
françois hollande ce que c'est une
thèmes dont on a beaucoup entendu parler
cette semaine son lit vg il veut créer
donc quasiment dans chaque centre
hospitalier même dans tous les centres
hospitaliers un centre dirigé qu'est ce
que vous en pensez c'est une très
mauvaise propositions et c'est une
proposition dangereuse pour les femmes
il y a mis à un ami lié un peu plus d'un
millier d'hôpitaux publics petits et
grands un millier d'hôpitaux publics et
nous avons actuellement à peu près cent
mille ivg instrumental ivg chirurgicales
le reste est fabriquée fait avec des des
techniques médicamenteuse ça veut dire
que dans ces centres dits vg y lire en
moyenne moins de deux ivg par semaine et
pour certains une ou deux par mois mais
en médecine on ne fait bien que ce qu'on
fait souvent il faut avoir des centres
ivg surtout que nous sommes dans des
périodes de pénurie encore pour
l'instant de deux chirurgiens
d'anesthésistes de personnel spécialisé
il faut avoir des centres dits vg
techniquement très complet avec une
palette complète de services cette idée
de françois hollande est unité
démagogique dangereuse pour les femmes
bien peut-être une dana question très
rapide saurait questions de société
comme l'homosexualité le mariage
homosexuel ou encore le net l'euthanasie
on a vu un retour en arrière une
droitisation du président sarkozy et du
candidat sarkozy
est ce que vous le regrettez on sait que
vous même vous étiez prononcé
vigoureusement pour le mariage
homosexuel
d'abord je vous arrête ces sujets ne
sont pas des sujets de droite ou de
gauche et je refuse de les labelliser de
cette façon ce sont des sujets de
société sur lequel chacun avance avec
ses convictions son histoire ses
connaissances historiques et
scientifiques et moi je ne la baie lis
pas les uns et les autres
je remarque d'ailleurs que au moment du
pacte civil de solidarité certain nombre
de députés parlementaires de
je n'y étais pas favorable moi je suis à
titre personnel favorable au mariage
homosexuel et à l'adoption
mais je le fais dans un esprit de
dialogue pour faire avancer les idées ça
viendra en temps et en heure merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame bachelot
merci d'être venus sur parlement hebdo
merci aux merci à l'avoir obligé